dea
き今から日本語のレッスンを行います
今日は日本の電車の乗り方を教えたいと思います宜しくお願いします
step 1作るのが面倒くさいから3週間ほど水かじゃなくて
切符を毎回毎回顔ステップに毎回毎回切符を買うことが面倒くさいからスイカを作る
steps
んスイカにお金を入れるポイントを焦ること
後ろの人に何度も何度も謝ること
水も設置 step 4位急いで財布に水カーカードを入れて改札を通る
step 4認識されないから財布に suica カード入れずに改札を通る号
step 5腕時計を見ながら階段を下りて本に向かうポイント少なくとも1カ月は
階段の上り下りに気付かず自由に再悪くこと
すいません
なるほど step 6ホームにつき急に焦りがなくなった状況に困惑する
デップ7電車が来るまで4期アプリで時間をつぶすポイント
アンティアプリでをなくインスタグラムを使うことを step 8
電車が来たらドアの部分に頭を強くぶつけて乗り込む年
9ああーっ step 9電車に乗っている間 sns まま新見のメッセージを送る
時々付
自然の英会話広告を見て英語が出来る自分に陶酔する
てっぷ10時間がないか観察する正義を守らなければならあの子可愛い step 11
再び頭をぶつけて電車降りる血中
ん
ねステップ中に階段を上って改札に向かうポイント
前を歩くミニスカートギャルのパンツを見ないこと観ないことを見ないことを見ない
こと step 13
改札を出る前にポカリスウェットを買って一息入れる
いないことおめでとうございますあなたは日本の電車を無事に step 14
認識されないから財布に水カーカード入れずに改札お豆腐 step 15
残金が足りないから改札の中でスイカをチャージする
ポイント日本の物価を非難することを韓国だったら10円もしないのに
ni